[Music]
hi guys alright it's such a fun movie I
couldn't keep up with all the dialogue
I'm like how did you guys memorize all
this it was so impressive and so this is
your fourth movie together right but it
had been I think about 10 years what was
it like for you two to be together on
set again to reunite it was the best
yeah that's I really I mean it was
really really great what makes him the
best um pretty much everything I've
always I mean he's one of my favorite
people to work with to be around and
yeah and I feel the same I mean I knew
that it was the movie would only work
with it
it's like someone that had a really
strong chemistry with and I always felt
like we do and and I love that guy I
like the gushing what do you love about
her same thing I mean I mean personally
yes he's a good friend sense of humor
intelligence mind you of the world
beautiful heart beautiful spirit and a
damn fine actress oh do you guys
remember the first time that you met
having worked together on all these
movies for all these years now
I do I met him it was acting and we
presented an award at the Independent
Spirit Awards back when it was like in a
room with folding chairs yeah Loki and
Roosevelt Hotel yeah
but there was like it wasn't kind of
what it what it is today but I remember
us very very excited okay this is
memorable you remember the exact you
mean you met each I and why I do that
well I have had I had a pretty healthy I
had a big healthy crush and and
you know anyway we had a wonderful time
making this film it's wonderful this is
two characters where it's impossible for
to fall in love or - well not to follow
them up yes maybe to fall in love and
they through the course of the film they
kind of I mean that they're opposites
but they're kind of two big healthy
crushes on each what happened to the
healthy crushes oh well the movies
destination wedding and some wild stuff
happens to your characters what's the
craziest experience you guys have ever
had at a wedding in real life mine is
when we got married
getting Dracula which I'm convinced we
really do get married because it was a
real Romanian priest and they did a
master that he did the whole thing
Coppola it's a couple of different and
no how are we not many think that
Romanian I don't know I mean I'm still
thinking I'm a lifer yeah okay well now
we know what happened she sealed the
deal I mean I guess they wanted to ask
you this movie is so much about a
wedding does did working on it make you
guys think about ever getting married
you to see yourselves whether it's to
each other anyone else ever gone down
that road come out of this film that
yeah you think about things like that
and and if you don't think it can be
possible or want then maybe this one
will change that perspective like oh
there Kent like I can't this can happen
I can't connect with someone like this
and and if you do then it's you know
it's great so yeah just working on this
Tuscany yeah me too keeps love alive
yeah
you
[Music]
[Applause]